thank you so much for
for taking the time to talk to me i've
got those posters that you have behind
you as well
i swear i've had them for months i'm not
like the guy who shows up at the concert
wearing like the band t-shirt so i'm not
i didn't put these up specifically for
no i mean it's funny i'm not in my study
i'm in an office but
in my study i have those poses on the
wall they're fantastic
they are amazing thank you again i'm a
huge fan of yours and
and have been for a long time i also had
to tell you the sparks brothers is still
my favorite film of the year so far uh i
love that movie so much oh thank you
well it's coming out soon as well
yeah i can't wait to see it in the
theater it's quite funny to be juggling
press for three different movies that
all have s in the title
here are soho sparks and scott pilgrim
yeah and one of which you made a decade
ago
it's crazy yeah well and kind of to jump
into that
you know i'm curious how long this kind
of dolby version has been in the works
and
and what all went into kind of this new
version of the film
you know i think it was something like
what has been really nice about scott
pilgrim is like for a film
that did not do that well on its
original release
like you know usually when that happens
a studio
is sort of embarrassed by it and it very
quickly goes to kind of like
dvd and blu-ray and it's maybe never
spoken of ever again
and the nice thing is is with scott
pilgrim that didn't happen
and they think sort of universal you
know
and it's one of those things that like
sort of i remember at the time there was
a lot
people kept asking me to sort of like
try and point the finger of blame
and people kept saying like oh is it
because of the poster
and people wanted me to point the finger
a blame of somebody and i would never do
that because a
i didn't necessarily agree and b i knew
that the
marketing department at universal
absolutely
loved the movie and and it is a funny
thing
michael moses who's like the head of
marketing at universal
um he sent me the best email
after like the monday after it came out
you know where like i was very proud of
the movie but is that weird thing where
you get emails from people where they're
like you know kind of
think that you might be suicidal or
something like i was like i'm well i'm
still promoting the movie i'm here in
london back here yeah so like i'm
keeping upbeat about things
and but he said the best email that i've
ever had about a movie
is the so it opens at number five you
know
i i deliberately that weekend i did not
read any of the trades i think
like it's not a good thing it's not it's
not useful in any way
to read like deadline of box office mojo
or any of those things so i didn't and i
still never have but he sent me this
email and all it said
was he said years not days
it was just like one of the best emails
about anything in my career i've ever
received michael moses just sent his
email and all it said was years not days
and i was thinking yeah i mean i know
because most of my favorite movies
didn't
make any money first came out the thing
you know like um big trouble in little
china there's i mean
that's two john carpenter films but i
could think of people
you know blade runner there's like tons
of them that obviously like
you think we're hits and then you
realize oh they weren't i wasn't a hit
when it came out
um you know it's funny like when you
look at big trouble in china it did not
even crack the top 10 when it came out
which is like insane but then i think
about when i saw it in 1986 i was alone
in the cinema
but anyway so the nice thing was i knew
that like people there
loved it and also because over the years
sometimes there's never been a call for
a sequel because i think it's just
something that that is
financially like not manageable but it
was kept getting
re-released on blu-ray as i mean more
[ __ ] funko pops than you could
you know like you could fill a house
with a
pilgrim and then like and then
occasionally you get calls from the
universal saying
is there anything else we can do with
scott pilgrim and you know and there's
still some
potential i can't speak out term but
there's still some potential things that
might happen in that regard
but with all that in mind i had said you
know me and michael have talked at some
point i said well
you guys should re-release it for the
10th anniversary everybody in the cast
is now a mega star like and there's
probably a lot of people you never saw
on the big screen
and he said hey let me get back to you
on that and then like he came back and
said dolby cinema
would like to do a version of the movie
and i said well that's amazing so
basically
dolby cinema and amc kind of partnered
up
and that's how the kind of dolby cinema
version came to be and for me it was
actually sort of
unlike having to remaster some of my
other films
this one was kind of like a kind of
complete walk in the park because
i'm still working with the mixer and the
editor
and you know and the dp and colorist
i've worked with very recently
so i could bring back the original team
and saying like hey
let's you know like and so what was
brilliant was like whilst i was doing
sparks in soho last year
julian slater finished um like
actually it was before he was sort of
doing around the same time is that
we were finishing off soho and sparks
and julian slater was in la
and had taken all the original stems and
basically remixed scott pilgrim in atmos
meanwhile stephen nakamura who was the
original colorist
also kind of like did his dolby cinema
4k version of it so i was in a very
privileged position of just
like watching what they'd done and had
like
no notes i mean maybe like one tiny
thing but it was sort of incredible
watching it and me and paul matchless
whilst we were finishing off soho went
to the dolby cinema in soho square
and sat there and watched a film that we
made 10 years ago and were like
whoa i always have this feeling when i
watch films i've made
especially something like scott pilgrim
i feel as even when i watch space
as i watch it and i think how the [ __ ]
did i do that
how the hell did we make that movie it's
like the actual like
shooting days and what you did on any
one day
has sort of evaporated from your head
and i'd have to look at the shooting
schedule again
just to figure out how that film came to
be so
you know and what's nice about it is the
i was also very aware that like there
are obviously people that
saw it at the time and loved it there's
other people who discovered it
on blu-ray or in you know repertory
screenings
and then the other thing i've become
very aware of is that like kids like it
and i know this because there's quite a
few directors
friends of mine who say to me hey would
you sign a scott pilgrim post for my son
i i i've definitely done ones there's
more than this definitely don't want to
be like sam mendes
like jj with john favreau
jack black just the other day that's
like hey could you sign the scott
pilgrim president with my son
so there's obviously like sort of like
some 10 and 11 year olds like who
obviously did not see when it first came
out who like loved that movie and i've
heard that a lot from people
so it's nice in a way like i think in a
strange way
even though it was supposed to come out
last summer the timing of it now
with like a push to
you know now the vaccine is making its
way around the world
like people are like slowly becoming
more comfortable with going back to the
cinema and congress
godzilla has proved that that there is
like sort of an audience that is waiting
to come back
that like the timing of it weirdly is
like perfect in a strange way and in
fact i heard the other day that brian
lee o'malley
tried to book tickets in los angeles and
it was sold out
that can only be good news well it's
kind of ironic because
and i i was going to ask you about that
year's not day's comment because i i
read that
and this film that a decade ago you know
was a box office disappointment
is now not only positioned perfectly for
people to go back to the movies and you
have this fan base
i'm sure many of whom have never seen it
on the big screen but also watching the
trailer again it's kind of ironic
because it's like chris evans aubrey
plaza brie larson is just this
packed cast you can market it as this
huge blockbuster event now
i mean i the funny thing is is that the
trailer
that they did and the new poster is like
my favorite trailer and favorite poster
that we've ever had
and i didn't make that comment to like
the producer i said where was this
posted 10 years ago
and also the trailer was like i mean
universal did the trailer again and i
was like
they showed it to me and again it was
that thing of like that's the funny
thing is
the trailer now you can like rattle off
all those names
back then there was nobody above the
title not even michael was above the
title
when you know it came out before um
but you know like i i can't listen i
have no like
i have no kind of like bitterness
at all for like how it did 11 years ago
it just doesn't matter and i sort of
knew that at the time even though it was
a tough
i mean basically when when that kind of
happens more what you're thinking is
like
will i be allowed to work again
that's your main priority is like will
they let me make another film
and so i i've been very fortunate to
kind of like and also you know i've
worked with
universal again um now
twice since and like you know maybe
about to do another one with them you
know so actually three times i guess
with sparks
so like you know so that that is it's
what makes me very happy is it's not
sort of considered a black mark for
anybody
it's like they're kind of like proud of
and like sort of becomes you know and it
like i said it's like
you know like you can sort of measure it
in how much merchandise
well and you mentioned um you know not
not knowing how you did it and the
making of doc i've seen a number of
times that every time i watch it i just
feel exhausted for you
just watching how you guys made that um
but i'm a huge fan of bill pope and i
wanted to ask you
um you know i i read that you know part
of hiring was
to kind of calm any concerns on
universal's part
of you handling a budget that big but i
was just curious how that relationship
started because
i mean you guys have worked together a
number of times since then and
you know how that collaboration went
forward and then what his reaction was
when you were like
this is what we're gonna do these are
how many different shots and setups
we're doing here
well it's interesting you mentioned that
because it was something that
you know uh and it's interesting because
jess hall who i've worked with on hot
fuzz who did an amazing job on that film
and is an incredible
talent like because we were both kind of
sort of up and comers with that film
it wasn't something where like because
universal were nervous about it
initially with bill initially it was
like a slightly
strategic thing is that like okay so
they're nervous about
what this is but they'll be less nervous
if i hire
the cinematographer of the matrix and
then you know and then it's and that is
exactly
initially the reason that i met with
bill is because then your universe will
be like oh
he's got the matrix guy okay this makes
sense now i get it which is sort of how
that works
however the thing with bill which was
the surprise
is that bill in terms of like
pitch in to answer your question
pitching it to him about this is what
we're going to do
bill has sort of done every shot that
has ever
existed so he is in the most brilliant
way kind of unflappable if he has the
kind of the time and the tools
there's nothing really that phases him
but that wasn't the thing is
that wasn't the thing that i really
loved about working with him and
still love working with him you know
it's because he really
for somebody who's like such a brilliant
visual artist
his main concern is about
the emotion and the characters so when i
met him
to talk about the scott pilgrim script
we only talked about
the emotional aspect of it and about the
characters and that side of it
so i came away from that meeting
thinking well that's unexpected
it was almost like he kind of like saw
was completely unfazed by my visual
ambitions
it was more focused on you know kind of
what was at the heart of the story
and and really that's something that i
he's so brilliant with actors bill
and he's such a brilliant um
he sort of really shoots actors in an
incredibly
kind of um what's the word um
but you know kind of like i say intimate
but it's
something that like he he gets the best
out of them
visually in terms of just kind of like
or
capturing what they do but making sure
they look amazing doing it
and i think you can see that you know
especially in like scott pilgrim and
baby driver
i i skipped over the world zen because
everybody's supposed to look terrible in
that baby
and that's uh maybe my favorite of your
films i i thanked
that film i think simon's incredible in
that movie he is i think that's simon's
best
performance i think he would agree with
that as well a big topic of
conversation among the fans is obviously
the ending and and you know the
the original ending is on the blu-ray
and i was always just curious from your
perspective
um i know that didn't test as well you
shot a new ending
what do you have a preference between
the two endings do you think
that one works no i think the theatrical
one is the one i think the thing is
is that we wrote that ending
and i think when we me and michael
because wrote that ending
brian had not finished the books he had
an outline
by the time he was all making it that
there were three books out
and brian had the outlines for the the
final
three but then brian didn't really stick
to those outlines he kind of just was
you know kind of having fun sort of
inventing it as he went along and i
think
once he'd read the screenplay i think in
a way that that
probably in a very george r.r martin way
it sort of encouraged him to sort of
like
well i'm going to do something different
because i think he wanted and i tell
himself
he needed ownership of the books
and so he said oh i know what they're
doing in the films i'm going to do
something different
so what brian eventually did was
different from the outlines that we
had and um and that was fine because i
kind of felt like
well this is okay for these things to
diverge you know it is an adaptation
and then i think the thing is the ending
that we'd written there was one
aspect to it which did not land and i'll
tell you why it didn't land
this i think me and michael because
originally we were trying to write an
ending
that was in the vein of the graduate or
the heartbreak kid
where like our hero gets what he wants
but maybe that
isn't what he needs and there was that
realization that kind of like he'd sort
of
you know won the battle but lost the war
and that was the idea of it but then
trying to do that
scene or that tone with ellen wong
the most adorable actress on the planet
it just didn't feel right it felt like
this is like this trying to do this kind
of ending
is unfair on knives and unfair on ellen
and so he basically didn't really shoot
the ending that we'd written
and so then what we originally test
screened was sort of like as it was on
the blu-ray
and some people really liked it and then
sometimes in test screenings people
would literally say
i mean there's some people i know that
really like the ending as it was
but you know sometimes you go to test
screenings i remember this
vividly we had this test screening where
we were like we'd scored like an
81 it was like the fourth test screening
we'd scored in 81 which is high
there's something in the focus group uh
and funny enough it's like somebody that
i i've
i figured out who it was afterwards
because we're sort of friends on twitter
it's this
lady called nicole clipper
all i was looking at was the back of her
head and i remember in a focus group
people were saying nice things about it
and then one hand came i said i love
this film i love every frame
i love every scene i love every
character i really really do not like
that ending
it was really like just other people had
said it
but nobody had said it in quite strong
terms so i went away
and i talked to michael mccall and brian
lee and mali about it
and i think universal thought that i was
going to be stubborn and just stick to
it i think they thought well 81 is good
and maybe the ending's a bit divisive
but like let's finish the movie i went
away
and i think i showed it to a couple of
people um
and maybe i showed it to jj abrams
actually i think i showed it to him a
lot
and i said to him that i was thinking
about a new ending he said what would
you change and i said well
i still been talking about a way of like
him getting together with ramona not in
a not in a way that's very conclusive
that the idea that it's like there's
like like maybe a chance to start over
rather than him just go off with her
like
and it'd be into the sunset it's more
the idea that they're going to start
again
and and he said uh he said you should
try and write that ending and see how it
feels
so that weekend me and brian lee
o'malley and michael mccall got together
and we
wrote what the new ending is and brian
leo melli
and this is what's great brian lee
o'malley helped us write the new ending
which was also different again from the
books but different from what we've done
and we're sort of trying to sort of
crack it and the key to it was
that knives lets him go and the real key
to it is brian lee o'malley's line which
is like he wrote this line
is knives line i'm too cool for you
anyway
that's it that's that's the line at the
line
and what was amazing then then i had
this thing
where i think i've told this story
before but it's true i was most
when we were gonna do the new ending i
was most nervous about
calling ellen wong because i worried
that ellen wong was gonna think oh so
i'm not the romantic lead at the end
he's gonna go off with ramona
okay so that sucks
but then i told her i said so we're
gonna shoot a new ending
and then when i told her what it was she
goes oh i'm so glad you said that
because i was thinking
knives is like too proud to take him
back and makes her look really weak that
she takes it back after he cheated on
her
and i was thinking oh thank god
jesus said and she said she goes oh i
love that line you know i'm too cool for
you anyway
so even that before we show anything and
thinking okay this is going in the right
direction
and um so we shot but we shot that scene
we shot all the new bits it was like
some other bits as well it's like it's
funny
there's little bits there's one like
meme from the film
that was like a late edition the little
shots of i tell you what we shot and was
like
um the stuff at the end including a bit
with young neil that we never put in the
movie so johnny simmons came
all the way to toronto that we ended up
thinking oh this is building the lily
let's take this out
it was literally the idea as soon as
like knives was single
like young neil came into frame with the
bass guitar
it was just one joke too many the
original ending still had the
uh [ __ ] scott thing with the kind of
the brunch thing that was all in there
it was literally the dialogue that they
had
so we shot the ending and then the other
things that we shot was like
gideon saying about like do you know how
long it took me to
um the line about do you know how long
it took me to put the league together
like two hours
the other thing that isn't you that's
funny that we we shot because we had no
punctuation
was when chris evans is going down the
rail
the shots of kieran and michael going
wow
we actually had to build the top of the
steps and we had to build the top of the
pyramid
so definitely like and i think some of
those extra things universal
like uh whatever like you can make that
work in the budget
fine but we only want the ending and i
was like we're gonna do the ending and
we can just
do these other little bits that's
basically how it panned out and then
but it was finished that was shot in may
uh i remember because i couldn't go to
my best friend's wedding i was
like in may and then for an august
release
so some long lead critics screenings
or with the original ending and then
there were some people i mean i think
the new ending is better
by miles and like as soon as we test
screen the new ending the
the the scores went up again um
but then occasionally people are saying
i can't believe he changed the ending
and i said it wasn't right it wasn't
right
i could ask you a million more questions
and i know i'm almost out of time for
you um
but i believe you alluded on twitter to
potentially re-releases of
maybe one or two or three of the
cornetto films
is that also in the works i didn't say
that somebody else
he asked me if that was happening and i
said i just i just uh replied and said
over to you dolby cinema
no i i did not say that but if they want
you sure
i will ask dolby cinema just make this a
summer of edgar wright movies just
release
all of your films again in theaters to
get leaders back ahead of soho
thank you so much i'm down if they want
to do that fine let's remaster them all
in dobby cinema
thank you so much for your time and you
know congrats on sparks brothers and
can't wait to see soho cool sounds good
man thank you
awesome take care bye